so I wanted to bring a little woman
power to the evening so my august first
thoughts were Janis Joplin or penny
Smith and then my research led me to
Ronnie Spector and she was singer the
ronettes and she is now considered the
first bad girl a rock and roll because
her band was the first to her heavy
black makeup and hike their skirts up
cut slits up the seven so the ronettes
not very metal but this is where it all
started first women her book is called
be my baby how I survived mascara
miniskirts and madness so she starts out
talking about Marie and Marie k Hoffman
was like big radio DJ at the time Marie
first put us on the build the Brooklyn
Fox for a springtime review in 1962
actually weren't exactly on the bill at
least not as their own nests he only put
the top 10 or 12 acts up on the Marquis
so we are one of the acts listed under
and others for those first few shows
Marie didn't even introduce us of the
Ronettes when he brought us out on stage
he called us his beautiful dancing girls
which is pretty much all we were at
first Marie also used us as background
singers for all the apps i couldn't sing
real well after a while he didn't start
letting us do one or two numbers on her
own we did twist and shout or what I'd
say anything as long as I had a fast
tempo that we could dance to that was
the key because more we shook her behind
and her tight skirts the louder the kids
when a blog it was during these shows
that the ronettes image was really born
my mother always told us to look for a
gimmick that would make us stand out
from all the other groups something that
made us different well being half-breeds
they were it's her sister her cousin or
in the band and her mom was black and
Cherokee and her dad was white so she
says well being half three
we were born different so we figured the
thing that set us apart from the other
groups was our look and sitting around
for hours on end in our dressing room
with the Brooklyn Fox we had plenty of
time to work on our look there was
nothing back there but mirrors chairs
and make up so we naturally past the
time trying on different looks Estelle
would grab an eyebrow pencil and say
let's extend our eyeliner then the three
of us would have a little contest to see
who could extend her eyeliner the parts
then we'd start in on the lashes we all
lay mascara on until our eyelashes were
out to hear the nedrow and grab a rat
tail comb and run to the mirror shouting
let's tease her hair she teased her hair
until she could stack it about three
feet on top of her head then of course
Estelle and I would try and top her we
looked pretty wild by the time we got
out on stage and the kids loved it then
clap and make noise as soon as they saw
us walk out and the louder they
applauded the more mascara we put on the
next time we didn't have a hit record to
grab their attention so we had to make
an impression with our style none of it
was planned out we just took the look we
were born with and extended it a lot of
people commented that the ronettes
looked Chinese maybe we did but it
wasn't conscious we never tried to look
like any other race if we copied
anything it was a look of a girls we'd
see on the streets of Spanish Harlem the
eyeliner and
hair that's what we saw me grew up so we
brought it to our act of course we
exaggerated onstage because everything
on stage has to be bigger than life but
when people ask me where the Ronettes
got their street image I always tell
them we got it from the streets we may
have look like Street girls but I think
the audience could tell that under all
that makeup we are really just three
innocent teenagers and I think they like
that combination the girls loved us
because we were different we followed
our own style and didn't care what
anybody thought and the boys liked us
for obvious reasons throw nuts were what
the girls want it to be and what the
guys dreamed about so when audience
started responding to our street look we
played along the songs we sing are
already tougher than the stuff the other
groups did well the cherrelle is saying
about their soldier boy we were telling
the guys turn on your Lovelight we
weren't afraid to be hot that was a
gimmick when we saw the Shirelles walk
on stage and their wide party dresses we
went in the opposite direction and
squeezed our bodies into the tightest
skirts we could find then we get out on
the stage and hike them up to show our
legs even more after a while it got to
be so much trouble hiking these skirts
up and we finally just cut slits up the
side that was the ronettes look and we
definitely made an impact after our
first engagement at the brooklyn fox
marie could see our popularity growing I
mean to have no hit records and still
have kids waiting backstage to tear up
close off it a pretty obvious that we
had something special that's amore
started using us on the radio show every
night we spent most of 1962 waiting for
one of our records to hit it was a long
wait after what's so sweet about sweet
16 flopped on Cole picks sue Phillips
put our next two records out on May
records which was cold pixie's rhythm
and blues label but it didn't seem to
matter what they
while they were on nobody was buying our
records period I'm going to quit one
ahead didn't sell any better than our
first single we couldn't figure out why
our stuff wasn't selling but listening
to those songs today I can see why they
didn't make it whole pigs had no idea
what to do with us sue Phillips just
didn't know what rock and roll was I
mean he had us in the studio backed up
by two fake McGuire sisters it with the
strange songs he picked for us it's no
surprise a recording career was going
nowhere thank God for the Brooklyn Fox
hit or no hit the audience made us feel
like stars and by now Murray booked us
on every show he did at the Fox I still
have a program for one of the shows we
did a couple years later in September of
1964 when the artists included
shangri-la's Marvin Gaye the miracles
Supremes Martha and the Vandellas the
contours the temptations The Searchers
jay and the americans the devil's little
anthony and the imperials and the new
beats all that and a movie for two
dollars and fifty cents can you believe
it of course we didn't get along with
everybody I couldn't stand the shells
when we're just starting out they were
the headliners and they didn't want to
have anything to do with the other
groups but when they were stuck up the
Shirelles were the only girl group with
their own valet I mean to have him valet
even had to be superstars and they sure
thought they were these girls would not
even come out of their dressing room
until they were ready to go onstage and
then they hardly spoke to you they just
walked straight out to the stage with
their ballet waiting in the wings the
Shirelles looked at us like we were
little nothings I just said well gee
Dusty Springfield was another one I'll
never forget she shared a dressing with
us once and I never saw anyone gets so
frustrated backstage she hated being
stuck back there all day and night and
she expressed her frustration
dishes all the dressing rooms opened out
with this long hallway and at the end of
this hall was a big exit door that led
to the stage when dusty springfield got
upset she would go out to the hallway
and throw cups and saucers at the stage
door by the second show you had to step
over piles of broken china just to get
to the stage after she broke every dish
into place she'd send her ballet out to
lamson's five-and-ten-cent store to bite
more this poor guy would come back with
a whole box of white cups and saucers
for Dusty Springfield to throw at the
exit door she break dishes for five
minutes and she walked back into the
dressing room with a big smile on her
face I guess it helps relieve your
tension but we all thought she was nuts
I never could understand the craziness
of some performers rock and roll came so
naturally to me I didn't understand what
all the fuss and frustration was about